hello everybody welcome to cloud on air
I'm Evan Jones and with me I'm Julian
and we'll be talking to you on one of
these webinars you're gonna see every
Tuesday we're excited to kick off
today's about getting the most out of
your data and this is from data two in
science with Google cloud platform this
is ultimately going to be a teaser or
preview of a longer course that you can
take either on-demand or in an in-person
session so hopefully we'll get you
excited enough today with some pretty
cool demos three cool demos that we're
going to show you a little bit later you
can ask a side of the the chat box and
we have live Googlers standing by so if
you have a question on the demos or a
question about the course materials or
anything like that just type in your
questions even though we're talking
you'll have a lot of Googlers answering
those for you as well so why don't you
say we get started let's do it all right
so first off a little about ourselves
who are these folks here in front of you
so you might have seen me from some
previous webinars
I'm a technical curriculum developer and
for Google cloud my specialty is big
data and machine learning so topics like
bigquery or some of the machine learning
API is that you can access right now I
like building super fun courses out of
them and then recording them live on
here for you to for you to take but
sometimes a lot of people accuse me of
saying well you know you know not
necessarily might have the latest and
greatest of what there is out in the
field so with me I brought an amazing co
home when we have so hi my name is
Julian Philippe and I'm a surgeon's
architect our Google Cloud my role is to
work with customers and help them plan
for the migration of their workloads to
DCP I've lived in in various parts of
the world in Reunion Island France and
Australia as evidence here in a photo
mingling with the locals and Morrison we
have moved to San Francisco six years
ago which is where I'm based now we'll
get started yeah let's do it she'll you
definitely get points for the more
creative photos so let's talk a little
bit about what we're gonna cover today
so you learn a little bit of about us
and we're gonna overview what generally
we're gonna cover right now so as I
mentioned this is gonna be big data and
machine learning focused and this is
gonna be like a very high-level overview
in the slides and then some deeper dives
into the demos they're going to do just
me three things you might have already
heard of bigquery we're gonna go into a
quick demo of that it's ad hoc query
processing platform and we have cloud
data prep and Julian's gonna walk you
through a pretty cool demo if you're
ever interested in how to clean
dirty data and a more automated in GUI
fashion and last night at least we're
gonna end with some machine learning
concepts so this is accessing machine
learning API is in a friendly way
through a data lab notebook they're
going to cover and all three of these
demos and all the content behind them is
covered in much more greater detail in
the course so hopefully this will get
you jazz and excited to launch and take
that Coursera course fully well you see
we get started is there this let's do it
alright so today companies face a lot of
pinpoints they have to deal with a huge
amount of structured data and or
structured data unfortunately they don't
always have the technical expertise and
infrastructure to process the data and
then also that data terms do come in
different forms with varying levels of
quality and that makes it difficult for
to extract value from that data so as a
result it's it's that does insight tend
to be locked up in opaque data and it's
also difficult to share it amongst
stakeholders so this is why companies
tend to miss out on a huge opportunity
to expand their businesses and this is
where guca platform comes in go kappa
from a fully managed turnkey system to
visually explore clean proper structure
there are an extra two data to analyze
at scale with minimal technical
expertise as men Evan just mentioned
we're going to run you through a few
demos of some of the products are
available on our platform and to show
you how easy they are to operate all
right so let's give this kind of webinar
a little bit broader context so today
hopefully you're coming here and you
might have used like sequel or if you're
not familiar with how to kind of ask
questions in your data you're in the
right place we're gonna demo from the
sequel slide in bigquery to the data
cleansing side and data prep to the
machine learning side and some of the
data lab notebooks that we're going to
be working with so this is just
generally to get you primed and ready to
potentially jump in and take that
Coursera course tomorrow and then later
on there if you wanted to say well I
really really enjoyed these concepts and
I'm really enthused to learn more about
machine learning what other courses do
you have on data engineering or
application infrastructure or kubernetes
and container deployment though is for
the step three you can take whatever
tracks that you
available on-demand through our Coursera
courses there or in-person training as
well so this is just your the start of
your journey honestly so hopefully at
the end of this what you'll get is just
a little bit of appreciation for it some
of the tools and technologies I'm Google
cloud platform can do but it's by no
means the end so just to kind of kick
off this in general content context a
lot of folks ask well alright there's a
lot of tools and products in Google
cloud platform what does Google do it
really well as you can see here from the
Forrester chart Google is a leader in
what I would say is some of the current
offerings for big data and machine
learning specifically so when folks are
asking like alright well I want to get
more of a well versed in the data space
where should I start so oftentimes
they'll jump in the Google call platform
and then use a tool like bigquery which
as you're gonna see you don't need to
set up your own server infrastructure
you don't need to worry about the
scalability adding more Hardware over
time so you have a like a black friday
sale and you're worried about whether or
not that data that the massive amounts
of data that's coming into your
warehouse if you're gonna have to have a
ton more servers to query that type of
data so it's server listening a little
bit scale its scalable to 2 petabytes of
of data but a lot of times we get faced
with this blank blank stare so you walk
into the Google cloud platform and it's
exactly that it's a platform on many
different products and services and a
lot of folks don't necessarily know
which is the best place to start so for
this particular webinar we're gonna
focus in on what you see directly there
in the middle which is going to be your
data in analytics so the reason why it's
called Google cloud platform cloud
because it's scalable you don't need to
worry about the server's infrastructure
behind the scenes and platform as you
see that bottom bar offer as many
different products and services that you
can build on top of it that's why it's
called the platform and then obviously
we can't cover all of those topics today
in just the short amount of time that we
have so what me being completely biased
and really enjoying the data and m/l
ones we're gonna jump into those six
icons that you see there first bigquery
then data prep and then through data lab
we're gonna be accessing those three
machine learning api's on the right so
as we covered we're gonna take a look at
bigquery data prep and the Machine Lang
api's but it's best done through real
demos so let's go ahead and jump right
in bigquery itself
answers the question of how do I do a
data analysis I'm a business
intelligence professional how do I do
data analysis
scale in a meaningful way without having
to manage servers or infrastructure and
it deals with a lot of the general
problems that you might see in the
day-to-day world so for example how do I
get tons of data in petabytes of data
and well you can import it into bigquery
how do I transform that data in a
repeatable way well you can do that
either through sequel and bigquery or as
Julian's going to show you inside of
cloud data prep for some pretty fun
Wranglers how do you deal with storage
how do you deal with the analysis the
data and ultimately how do you visualize
the end of those results this is the day
in and day out life of a data analyst or
a business intelligence professional
it's been my life for the last 10 years
getting folks excited about sequel but
also in the last couple years a lot more
tools that make data analysis and
processing visualization a lot easier
and arguably a lot more fun too so that
said it's demo time
let's jump into the first demo which is
going to be using bigquery to process
over 10 billion rows about 500 gigabytes
and we all we can test it to see how
fast it does so first and foremost I'm
gonna jump into Google bigquery and
again it's part of the course we're
gonna go through a lot of the different
bells and whistles of the UI and where
you can find things here but first and
foremost all you have to know is that
you can write sequel which is the
structured query language that you ask
questions of your data into this box
here so you have where you write sequel
queries and you get answers back it's in
the simplest case how I normally would
teach the courses you say alright well
give me which is just a fancy way of
setting select five and five as you can
see if you run the query you get ten as
a result back there you're saying okay
Wow
well sequel big query is nothing more
than you know a really big calculator
and yeah well that's true extrapolate
this say you didn't have five and five
but you had it an order like the
quantity times the order but say you
wanted to actually pull data from a
particular table so that this pre can
query they're gonna pull open here and
what you're looking at is the sequel
query that selects the language the
article title and the total number of
views that each of the pages and
wikipedia has and not only does it do
the output it filters for each of the
different pages where the title you see
the wild-card operator has Google
somewhere in the name so if you know
Wikipedia you know that there's tons and
tons and tons of pages out there
millions if not billions of there
pages so let's see how long it actually
will take to process all of these so I'm
going to run this query and in addition
to pulling all those records it's doing
these aggregations behind the scenes and
it's doing this wild card operation to
see the titles where it's matching
Google and then it's showing the pages
that have the most views first the most
interesting thing yeah the results are
down here but the thing about what makes
bigquery bigquery is if you look here on
the right you'll see that in about 11 or
12 seconds it processed through 416
gigabytes of data so massive amounts of
data you just put your data inside of
bigquery and then run these ad hoc
queries on top of it without having to
worry about spending updated database
servers or managing software or anything
like that behind the scenes interesting
it's also an exploration tool so if you
wanted to see well what are the other
public data sets that are available out
there inside of bigquery you can see
that all right well there is some
weather data from NOAA going back to
1929 in a bunch of other publicly
available datasets because you might say
all right Evan I don't have a data set
that I can play around with
do you have example queries or do you
have example data that I can just get a
feel for what are some of the different
things like any with sequel and what are
the different types of things that I can
do with the data sources and data sets
that are out there so not only can you
query but you can also explore some of
the really cool data that's available
publicly both here inside the bigquery
UI and there's a great team that manages
the bigquery public data sets if you
just Google bigquery public data sets
and we'll drop the link into the bottom
you can see a lot of really cool data
sets that you can play around with all
right so bigquery again you can ingest
data you query it live it really fast
with inside of sequel that you write you
to learn more about what are the
different types of in advance the sequel
that you can do inside of bigquery
inside of the course and of course you
can run your queries save the results
store the results all right and as you
see here the results we have English for
the Google page that has me do my
accounting here nine million nine
million views for the English page we
have the Spanish page there for the
second result there and you can imagine
that if you wanted to change any part of
your query you just adjust the query
here and you can return the new results
there as well that's the tip of the
iceberg when it comes to bigquery you
can re-execute queries one of the things
that I
like to do almost as a trick for the
students in the course is if I reran it
do you think it'll run faster or slower
the same speed a lot of people will tell
it's the same right well the good news
about bigquery is it will actually store
your results cache behind the scenes
where it can and this query for example
took three seconds cached and it didn't
query 416 gigabytes of data because it
had already done that so it's a little
bit of intelligence that's built in
behind the scenes inside the
architecture I could go on and talk
length about bigquery but one of the
biggest things here is that this
Wikipedia data was already loaded and
more importantly already cleaned and
cleansed now I guarantee you the data
that you have inside of your
organization's is probably not only
siloed and different departments but
it's also unclean so say the act of
preparing your data converting dates to
the right date format truncating fields
that's often a pain to do especially by
hand or even sometimes with sequel and
we're gonna see next what a better way
to cleanse and explore that data is all
right switching back to the slide so
cloud data prep as if I'm just mentioned
to be able to do valuable analytics or
machine learning algorithms you need to
have data that it's in a clean State you
need the data to conform to some
integrative rules for example the data
has to be valid one example is that
numbers have to fall within the expected
ranch dates have to be properly
formatted another example is about
completeness you want to make sure that
you have all the data that you need if
you if there are some missing values you
have to be able to deal with that it may
be fetch the proper information to
complete the data uniformity is also an
important rule you want to make sure
that for example numbers are in the
right unit so that you can do proper
calculations however yes it is true that
in the real world it's very rare that
you are handed a clean data set to begin
with so that's why you have to do some
transformation on that data too
make it cleaner so that then you can do
proper analytics or machine learning
work with it so this is where a cloud
data prep comes in cloudberry preppies
cloud is google's self-service data
wrangling tool they are wrangling being
the process of taking data in its native
format and then making it usable for
analysis data prep is a UI best tool
there is no need to write any code and
it's very easily use so this is what I'm
going to show you now in in a demo ok so
what you can see here on the screen is a
data set which have just loaded in cloud
data prep it is a rig data set of about
a million records of fake credit card
transactions there's a fake just for the
purpose of this demo and so I'm gonna
walk you through the interface you can
see here all of the rows all of the
records and you can also see all of the
fields display on the screen let's take
a look at the submission date on the on
the Left which is where the times when
the date and times when the transactions
were made it looks like if you look at
the histogram which is which so at what
point in time those transaction were
made you can see two spikes there so
that looks interesting what's something
you can do is to look in the details
here and the current details to take a
closer look and yes indeed you can see
that they are some two spikes here two
months in time I don't know maybe there
were some marketing campaign that
happened that that's just we already
started to get some insight here it's
something but might want to look into
further later on you can see also data
prep shows you more they more
information like for example when which
day the week
data was recorded or which month of the
year so as you can see you can drill
down into each each column and then get
some more details about in that data
let's take a look at the transaction
amount column here what you can see here
the top is what
is called the data quality bar it gives
you some information about the quality
of the of that particular column here
you can see in particular there is a
dark grey stripe that means that there
are some missing values for some of the
records if I click on this we see that
it actually highlights all the records I
have a missing value that's called
something we can do
maybe we can decide for the purpose of
the of our analytics work we want to
remove all those records and that's very
easy to do here in the right you can
just select here add for the delete
delete Rose transformation and that's
going to automatically remove all of the
rows that have a missing value you can
see now that the dark stripe has gone is
gone
so for transaction amount we were
expecting to see some decimal values so
this is what I'm going to change the
type and now that witch-hunter type you
can see that there is a red bar this
means that some values are mismatched or
miss formatted let's take a closer look
I'm clicking on that and that highlights
all of the incorrect or mismatched
values incorrect
here there is also the dollar amount
right there so to be able to do some
calculation on those numbers we will
need to remove these characters and
there again this is something we can do
here by selecting a transformation here
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
replace and this is these are just
suggestions that automatically came yeah
these are just suggestions you it will
offer you a few suggestions of operation
that would typically do based on the
type of the currently you've selected
so here I've selected the replace
transformation and here I don't there's
also something that's really cool is
that you can preview the effect of your
transformation in the in that yellow
column that just appear so you can see
that here yes indeed USD character would
be removed however we also need to tweak
that transformation to also remove the
dollar sign so this is what I'm going to
do here by clicking edit and here in the
pattern that is match I'm going to
select USD as well as the dollar sign
and there you have it the dollar sign is
also going to be removed so now I can
just add this step in the recipe recipe
is basically a series of steps to of
transformation step that you want to
apply to your data set alright so now
we've cleaned up the transaction amount
column let's let's move on and look at
the transaction type transaction type
column contains the type of the
transaction it's it could be debit or
credit or an authorization something
that could be useful in some cases for
supporting national in it's useful to
create features that will extract
different types of the different values
that are available in a particular
column it's also useful for doing
aggregation calculation so something we
can do here is to split the column into
three separate columns one for each
value so this is what I'm gonna just
down here
oh sorry
just pick the wrong thing try again
alright stricter click create a column
for each unit value and there again you
can see the preview of what's going to
happen is going to insert a boolean or
one of zero one for each value all right
moving on to the credit card number
column i'm furiously writing all these
down so i can you know go on live yeah
so obviously that is pretty sensitive
information we might not not want our
data scientist you have access to the
information every one certain
screenshots at home exactly this is just
a fake data set anyway so you won't get
anywhere with that but yeah so this some
this is a case where data pipe could be
used to remove sensitive information
so here what i'm going to do i'm going
to add a new step in the recipe I'm
going to type replace to select the
replace transformation step select the
credit card column and then for the
pattern I'm going to select the first
twelve digits and I'm going to say
replace replace those digits with a few
stars at the beginning alright so that
way we ensure that the critical numbers
are totally analyzed alright and then
moving on to the email field you see
that there is another red stripe here
that means that some of the email
addresses are Mis formatted so some you
know something we might want our
marketing team to take a look at that
and maybe fix the fix the issue so here
I'm what I'm going to do I'm going to
create a new column with a flag and that
flag is going to be true for all all of
the values that are miss formatted and
that that way our marketing team can
then follow up with our users and then
try and fix and get the
the proper email address and then
finally look the location field here is
the field that contains two information
the legend along with you those two
information accompany each concatenated
in a same column it might be useful for
calculation purposes to speed those two
values so this is also something I'm
going to do here I'm going to add a
split step for the location column and
I'm going to spin it using the semicolon
character which is the one that is used
to separate those two values so now
that's going to create those two extra
columns now to make it easier to work
with that I'm going to rename those
columns the first one is latitude and
the second one
as long as you alright so now that we've
cleaned our dataset we basically worked
on a sample we want to apply those same
that same recipe of trans
transformations to the whole data set to
the million records that we have in our
source data set so this is where you're
ready to run a job when you run a job
it's going to use data flow behind the
scene to run all of the same
transformation step at scale for all the
your entire dataset you have the option
of outputting the clean dataset either
to cloud storage or to bigquery so by
default it's going to use a CSV file in
cloud storage so here I'm going to run
the job and it will take a few minutes
to run that is this is on the entire
dataset this this is going to run on the
Iron entire data set and you can see
here the job is running something that
you may also want to do is to schedule
these same jobs to be run every hour
every minute for every interval that you
want see if you expect to receive fresh
data from time to time so that was a
quick demo of data prep something that's
very easily used to do transformation on
your data that's excellent thanks Julian
I'm sure a lot of you folks as you were
watching the demo had a lot of questions
about well can I do this what about this
transformation
don't forget type in your questions into
the box below and again we love these
tools they were just as exciting to us
when they were first released as they
are to a lot of using them for the first
time so add those questions in try to
stump the co-hosts here and we'll answer
those in the Q&A section
all right last demo on the board while
that job is running let's jump back into
a little bit of machine learning so I
would say data prep is such a tough act
to follow because I've been working with
sequel for you know 10 years and just
seeing the the ease of which you can do
a lot of those transformations and it
handles the scheduling or like the
workflow component know even if you know
a lot of sequel a lot of you may be
screaming yes finally in the background
- so cloud later prep is super fun to
play wrong play along with so the only
thing that I could do to get the same
level of enthusiasm for that one is
introduce some of the cool things so you
can do what I call friendly machine
learning so
friendly machine learning means if you
already have if Google already has the
machine learning API is for things like
text classification redacting personal
identifiable information automatically
and they've had these models already pre
trained how can you you get easy access
to them so that's we're going to cover
next before we do that I just wanted to
do a little bit of an exercise take a
look at these two fruits even without
machine learning just think about our
heuristic Allah how would you classify
them as one of the other so how do you
might be thinking okay well obviously I
know just with my human intuition one on
the left is an apple or on the Wrights
an orange one of them's red one of
them's orange well orange ah let's
classify them based on color oh not so
easy so now what happens if I gave you
these images now what happens if I added
more fruits as you see on the right you
have not only something that's spherical
in shape ish a little bit oblong there
that mango is also multicolored so when
you're doing these hard coded rules or
like imagine building a big decision
tree of if this fruit is red then this
or maybe even if it has like a stem you
get into a very dare I say like hard
coded fashion of a ton of rules and
that's uh you know maybe a little bit
too much than you wanted to take on well
let's start with something easier how
would you classify say for example the
difference between this dog here and the
mop it's very easy to know the
difference between a dog a mop right
that's gonna be just like one of those
zero and one things not so much turns
out there's a lot of dogs out there that
look like mops this is just just an
example there so even for for humans you
know it's very hard to just sometimes
something that might seem like an easy
classification task gets you quickly
into hot water and the good news is with
machine learning the machines can pick
up and they don't learn these hard coded
rules so machine learning is all about
replacing these hard-coded rules or
heuristic rules with learned knowledge
from historical patterns that they've
seen so with Google photos for example
you feed in a ton of images of dogs and
mob so I say ton like millions of
Records billions of records of these
images and then the algorithms the
machine learning models get smart enough
to then classify this as say 99% sure
that this is a dog and not a mop so how
do you the ultimate question there is
how do you get access to these friendly
machine learning models where the
trainings already been done you can use
those five and this is that's just the
tip of the iceberg for some of the
pre-training FML api's those five there
on the right and as we're gonna demo or
if you're saying well there's not really
a pre trained ml API for my use case
that's when you would use something like
Tenzer flow or the cloud machine
learning engine to write your own model
code and then train your own models but
again the training step for model and
more importantly getting that really
rich historical data is oftentimes one
of the hardest efforts and you can skip
that step almost entirely by invoking or
using some what I'll call these friendly
machine learning api's so let's look at
each of them in turn and then I'll show
you a web browser demo where you can
access them yourself and I'll show you
how you can actually use that
programmatically and begin to think
about ways that in your jobs maybe you
not be might not be working with images
as you see here is just a simple
classification of I tried to trick the
model a little bit with this camouflage
owl obviously it was able to pick that
out pretty pretty quickly but say you
have a lot of text so say you had like
customer reviews or product reviews and
you wanted to mine that for sentiment or
syntax analysis you can do that with the
natural language API as well so I'm just
gonna show you very quickly you don't
have to do this now but if you're
watching this video again you could go
to cloud.google.com slash natural
language as you see there in the browser
and then you can say analyze and this is
the browser version where you just have
text that's fed into there and the pre
trained model behind the scenes looks
for different entities so it basically
says all Google we think Google is an
organization based on the text that you
input it here also you're talking about
Android and users and this is about a
customer Electronic Show for Google and
you can say well let's write the
sentiment analysis is it positive or
negative and you can say foam from zero
to one green being positive and closer
to
and red being negative closer to
negative one again this is a slightly
positive sentiment so Google in this
particular case is announcing a new
product so naturally the next question
is all right well you're showing me this
inside of a web browser demo how do I do
that for my data without having to come
back here and copy and paste all that
text at the same time and that's why I'm
going to introduce you to one of the
last tools in the toolkit that's covered
as part of the course which is a data
science notebook or a cloud data lab is
the product the notebooks if you're
familiar with ipython or jupiter
notebooks this is exactly this is going
to look familiar to you so inside of
google inside of cloud data lab what I
have here is this ml api's ipython
notebook and this is gonna be one of the
labs in the course that you're going to
take I'm actually going to reconnect and
what you see here is a lab that we've
written for you and inside a lab
notebook are two different types of text
that you're going to see so if you're
familiar with sequel inside of bigquery
just chopped jumping over there very
quickly you'll see that it's pretty much
all code and then if you have a very
friendly developer if you'll also have a
little bit of comments that are thrown
in there as well if you're lucky inside
of cloud data lab notebooks I like to
say that it promotes code commenting
it's almost like an equal class as the
actual code so you have these cells that
are code and then you have the cells
that are marked down or pretty much
anything that you want to have like
texts or links or something like that to
so it reads more like a story so if
you've ever worried about like looking
at code not understanding it cloud data
lab notebooks will pretty much allow you
to tell a cohesive story with with one
long notebook so our goal here is to
play around with a lot of machine
learning a pee eyes that are available
so I'm going to do is I have an API key
that's been authenticated the for API is
that are part of this lab released
adhere I'm all you're just gonna go
through a few so you can get a
familiarity with it so those of you
familiar with google translate we're
just gonna invoke the Google Translate
API with just a few lines of code here
and all of these labs and all of these
demos
are publicly available in the course
repository and so what I'd highly
encourage you to do don't focus on
memorizing and regurgitating verbatim
the code that you see here you can
always start with this notebook as a
template and then swap out where the
data comes from to maybe your own data
sources or play around with them
yourself so let's see if I wanted to
convert the data input this is using the
service is it really this easy or
amazing technology or wow I'm gonna
actually you can just edit these I'm
gonna say terrible and then I can just
run this particular code and then you
see this just this section of code runs
bottle and then transfer
and it will come back with the
translation based on the language inputs
that we've set in which in this
particular case that we're sourcing it
to English and hoping for the target and
any language in Fr which is French I
need to reset my session
all perfect now that we're reconnected
I'm actually going to sometimes to
conserve resources the data lab
notebooks will pause just to make sure
that they're not using resources behind
the scenes so sometimes what you might
have to do is just reconnect the current
notebook session
let me just make sure that cloud deulim
ah the cloud shall all right so in the
interest of time what I might do is well
save this for a demo that I'm gonna
upload a little bit later because I have
this a little bit pre done and what I
might do is we're gonna pause for
questions that you have based on what
you've seen so far and while we pause
I'm gonna do is just restart this
restart this box and then we'll do the
demo and just quickly after the sessions
so if you haven't finished typing the
questions that you want answered there
and what we'll do is we'll come back
after a minute and then I'll fix this
and we'll get you up and running with
some very easy and friendly machine
learning we'll be right back
you
all right welcome back we have a lot of
awesome questions that we can't wait to
answer but to almost vindicate myself
I'm gonna do a quick demo what happened
is my machine decided to go to sleep
behind the scenes yeah but I'm gonna get
you a little bit of familiarity with
some of the the translation so let's see
if we can't translate amazing technology
with the technologies you see here is it
really this easy is it really this hard
and let's translate that into French
we'll test our French here difficile
there you go my friend that's it I can
you can not sure it is correct so the
translation works and then what I really
like about these these next few is we
optically character Lee recognized I
just made that up by the way we OCR this
image here and then extract the text and
then translate it from different
languages so for these pre-trained ml
models you can layer them on top of each
other as well pretty cool so this is the
vision API where you run that the image
is just serving from is in Google cloud
storage which you may already be
familiar with so you could have your own
JPEG that you could switch into there
it's recognizing all the characters and
parts of the text there and then it
prints out basically saying hey this is
the language this is the locale and then
all right use that as an input to then
translate it so a lot of the best
machine learning models like you've seen
the ones where you just point your phone
that say you're visiting overseas and
China or something like that where
you're just pointing your phone at the
sign it actually uses multiple machine
learning models behind the scenes in
this case we translated to please love
and respect hygiene to create a
beautiful water environment there last
but not least very quickly one of my
favorite ones is we've ingested some
poetry here and we're looking at whether
or not it's central analysis positive or
since their analysis negative and the
strong magnitude based on that so this
one is to succeed you must have
tremendous perseverance and tremendous
willpower so now I'm expecting that one
to be very high magnitude which it is a
polarity is one which means it's very
positive and very very strongly positive
where is let's say this last one
negative one when somebody love dies and
you're not expecting it
you know you don't lose it all once you
loser in pieces over time so pretty we
get inside think about that that's
negative one and that's a decently
strong point for magnitude and again
these are just these pre-canned examples
that we have here just by running these
notebook cells use these labs when you
take the course and I would say edit
feel free to edit this at your leisure
add in your own text connect to your own
data sources because I'd like to say
good artists copy great artists steal
so steal with pride when you see these
demos and a lot of the pre can code that
we have alright we have about five more
minutes and we definitely want to answer
a lot of the questions you've been
asking if you have questions
additionally for this machine learning
stuff that you didn't get a chance to
ask and type in be sure this video will
persist for folks who want to watch it
later add your questions even after our
talk all right we're gonna jump into the
Q&A all right let's see if they've
stumped us first question with the
results set in cache inside a big query
automatically get invalidated if the
data set changes somebody's definitely
play with bigquery and that's absolutely
true
so cache isn't validated any time the
underlying data changes and the cool
thing is there's a lot of metadata
associated with your tables inside of
bigquery where you can actually look to
see when the table was last updated or
last modified and you can actually query
is that particular metadata as well I
guess peek more at length take the
course we go into some pretty cool
performance characteristics in cache
let's see can you you want to the next
one yeah I guess I could I can you
record these transformation suggestions
desire to be to be able to apply to
subsequent sets of data yes the answer
is yes you can those types are recording
in the recipe and we can reply the same
steps to whatever data set that you want
yeah it's super useful if you're
collaborating with other people you can
actually commit your recipe to like
version control or something like that
and basically have recorded versions of
recipes as the recipes evolved in the
selves over times all right you want to
throw a different one quick question for
data prep we have data persisted in
multiple tables can data prep brown on
top of the bigquery
so that we can pull the data from across
different tables the answer is yes you
can not only pull data from the query
bureaus from multiple
you can mix and match data coming either
from cloud storage and bigquery and you
can join those datasets together so yeah
the answer is absolutely yes
all right when data arrives periodically
can you automate such data wrangling
programmatically instead of the UI so
you have potentially a denier here yeah
so data prep is a UI driven tool if you
if the transformations available in
daily prepare earning enough for the
purposes of your the work you have to do
on your data set then this is where you
want to use data flow instead data flow
is the backend behind data bread which
allows you to write down code that's
much lower level but you also have much
more control to write very specific
transformations so yeah your answer is
that if those transformation are very
specific you would want to use data flow
instead okay how long does a proper job
usually take it depends on the size of
the data set the complexity of the
recipe and the transformation the job
that I just ran earlier took about 10
minutes so just to give you an idea
great Wendy would you use I think you
answered this in part data prep versus
using something like data flow so data
prep would I would use for exploration
purposes because you already start
getting some visual insights about your
data you can play around it can preview
the effect of your transformations and
in some sometimes it's actually enough
to you to do simple transformation and
again if you have more complex more
specific or granular transformation you
wanna do it and this is where you want
to use data flow cool last family so
what are the performance considerations
for big core data sets so we have entire
module of the course dedicated to making
your queries high-performance and making
your data sets high-performance but just
off the top of my head anytime you're
doing transformations make sure you're
only using the data that you actually
want to transform that means if you can
filter your data with like a where
clause or really a filter early and
filter often also if you're a beginner
to intermediate sequel there's some
really advanced sequel concepts that we
go through in detail inside the course
like unnecessary
has inside of it like to drill down
records so if you have a customer and
you have all the orders associated with
them
normal related relational database
schema would say separate the two but
it's a a big query you can actually
store parent-child records within the
same table and you get the performance
benefits of automatically pre joining
the tables without having to do it like
an expensive sequel joint operation if
that went way over your head take the
course there's a lot of really really
good topics on performance we go into
data prep in a lot more detail and you
know I think you'll be honest they have
a blast I think we have a few more links
to show just for folks who are
interested in grabbing the so this is
the final slide that will just show for
you all so this is to access Coursera
courses this is to take those quick labs
which are like those labs that you saw
us going through and those notebooks
automatically in the last but at least
if you wanted to see what all the other
courses that are that are available that
last link is there but the good news is
this is just the start of your webinar
series today so although we kicked it
off today with just three of the
different tools be sure to stay tuned
for the next session which is cloud ml
engine 101 and we're gonna put you over
live to Kirkland see you guys later
nice job thanks for tuning in right